monsieur le ministre depuis maintenant
deux mois en marge des manifestations
des gilet jaune un certain nombre de
centres villes de notre pays sont chaque
samedi le théâtre de violences et
d'affrontements inacceptable
on ne compte plus les commerçants
artisans professions libérales qui ont
vu leurs locaux attaquent et dégradés ou
pillées quant à ceux qui ont la chance
d'échapper à ce déchaînement gratuit de
haine ils vivent dans l'angoissé c'est
médias venir et concepts de semaine en
semaine
la mort dans l'âme le déclin de leurs
activités craignant pour leur sécurité
les clients délaissent en effet
massivement les centres-villes chiffre
d'affaires en baisse de plus de 40%
chômage technique licenciement constitue
aujourd'hui le lot quotidien de nos
commerçants artisans restaurateurs
hôteliers l'avenir si rien ne change si
rien n'est fait pour les soutenir
une très probable explosion du nombre de
dépôts de bilan
or monsieur le ministre ces commerçants
et ses artisans jouent un rôle
économique mais aussi sociale plusieurs
municipalités consciente qu'il ne peut
exister de centre ville sans commerces
vont prendre des mesures d'urgence c'est
le cas de toulouse où un conseil
municipal exceptionnel examinera un plan
de dead de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros
mais les communes ne peuvent pas tous
les maires prennent leur responsabilité
l'état doit également prendre les
siennes plusieurs propositions d'aidé
individualisée seront demandés notamment
l'exonération non le saint et non le
simple report des charges sociales
patronales pour les mois de décembre et
de janvier de l'acf ainsi que le report
de la mise en application de la révision
des valeurs locatives commercial
monsieur le ministre
entendez-vous le désespoir des
commerçants et artisans des centres
villes comptez-vous leur venir en aide
c'est urgent pour vous répondre la
parole est aux ministres de l'économie
et des finances monsieur bruno le maire
et madame la sénatrice micouleau je
partage totalement ce que vous venez de
dire j'ai l'occasion il ya plus d'un
mois de dire que ces violences
ces dégradations de commerces de
magasins ces pillages était inacceptable
et qu'ils avaient un impact
catastrophique sur notre économie
je maintiens ces termes la violence les
dégradations les pillages les menaces
contre des commerçants sont
inacceptables et ont un impact
catastrophique sur notre économie est
toujours sur les plus petits commerces
surtout ceux qui ont des commerces de
centre ville qui ne peuvent plus exercer
librement leurs activités
c'est un impact également sur les
grandes surfaces tour du mal à
s'approvisionner
ça a eu un impact considérable sur la
restauration sur l'hôtellerie dans une
période de fêtes qui est normalement une
période le chiffre d'affaires est élevé
cela n'impacte très important dans des
secteurs très spécifiques
le jouet l'alimentation l'habillement
nous allons faire le bilan des soldes
d'ici quelques jours pour voir l'impact
concret que cela est ce vous confiant
que nous avons mis en place la cellule
d'urgence au ministère de l'économie et
des finances nous y travaillons avec
muriel pénicaud
la ministre du travail pour que nous
puissions avoir cet allègement de
charges pour ceux qui ont été le plus
touché nous restons en permanence ouvert
au dialogue avec les représentants des
commerçants et des artisans
je vous confirme également que nous
avons sollicité des assureurs pour
qu'ils répondent le plus rapidement
possible aux difficultés de ses
commerçants et puis nous sommes en train
de faire un bilan précis de l'évaluation
de l'impact économique du mouvement en
cours et des violences auxquelles elles
ont donné lieu pour que nous puissions
mesurer précisément l'impact de ce
mouvement sur la croissance française et
sur notre écho de bi en tout cas ma
porte comme celle de miel et pénicaud
reste ouverte en permanence aux
parlementaires qui le souhaitent aux
représentants des commerçants des
artisans de toutes les activités
économiques pour que nous travaillons
ensemble aux solutions les plus
efficaces possibles
merci j'aurais salué dans cet hémicycle
madame
françoise ramon notre nouvelle collègue
sénatrice d'eure-et-loir depuis le 2
janvier
moi